Virginia Department of Health is
celebrating the beginning of pride month
by promoting an organization called
queer kid stuff you couldn't make this
up the Virginia Department of Health is
promoting an online chat service
marketed to minors I just want to talk
to them teenagers who identify as lgbtq
plus what do they say queer kid stuff
kid is right there in the name it's an
lgbtq plus and Social Justice website
for kids and families the site includes
links to helpful resources videos and
more according to the Virginia
Department of Health it's not called
queer family stuff it's not being
marketed to parents it's being marketed
to little kids